each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
yeah good morning welcome to cloud
computing session our first presenter is
jelly from University of Virginia and
he's going to talk about modest modest
okay so good morning if my name is Julie
and today I will present that will work
in the construction of modest satellite
data reproduction and reduction pipeline
in Windows Azure so this work was
originally an internship work in
Microsoft Research in Lawrence Berkeley
Lab and has now continued to be a joint
effort between also between University
of Virginia assange group and University
of California at Berkeley and Lawrence
Berkeley Lab Microsoft Research so
Ethan's today has entered a data
intensive computing error in which the
increase in data availability is much
faster than the increase in
computational power so in recent years
many large scientific equipments were
has been deployed to produce
continuously a large amount of data and
also the emerging large-scale
inexpensive grant based sensors has
further provided ubiquitous data
availability so in this so this nearly
explosive increase in data has provided
a rich repository for scientific
discoveries and more and more science
applications are now applying
large-scale data intensive computational
models with increasing complexities
however a problem many scientists are
still facing today in data intensive
computing is that how to process the raw
data in order to produce the scientific
results there is a huge
there is usually a huge gap between the
raw data and final scientific results
and sometimes scientists can even do
nothing with the raw data even though
they're right there there there are
several reasons for this problem for
example scientists often meet with some
kind of barriers when they need to
process the raw data first they may have
computational resource entry barriers
this is especially true for some small
research groups in which they may have
very limited local computational
resources but even for some larger
groups who can have access access to
some national scale supercomputing
centers the system level support by
provided by those centers may still be
constrained and they may not be flexible
enough to provide the scalability as
required by different applications and
the other type of barriers is what we
call data entry barriers so data entry
barriers involves many aspects in data
processing and three common ones i
listed here the first barrier is data
collection scientists today are usually
not limited to a single data source and
but rather they tend to do more
comprehensive analysis over multiple
sources of data so this data must be
collected and assembled into a common
place in the second barrier is data
transformation so these multiple data
sources may have very rich heterogeneous
data formats and misaligned data
properties so they must be transformed
into a unified format before scientists
can do an analytical computation and the
third barrier is data management so such
huge amounts of data requires a very
deliberate software architectures to
orchestrate the complex scientific
workflows and to help manage the huge
data sets and these barriers are more of
computer technology domain problems
rather than science domain problems
but they are very common in many data
intensive science research today so this
raises a question do scientists need to
be computer experts as well but
unfortunately but fortunately we think
the answer could be no and in this
presentation I will introduce a
particular instance of this problem and
discuss how we can propose solutions to
lower the barriers for scientists and
our specific project involves the
Mahdists the data satellite data
processing and modest is short for
moderate resolution imaging
spectroradiometer this is the key
instrument onboard two satellites called
terra and aqua which were launched in
1999 2002 respectively and these two
satellites are viewing the entire
surface every one to two days and are
acquiring data in 36 different spectral
bands and these data are further
processed and separated into multiple
data beta products such as atmosphere
products and land products and ocean
products etc and this this modest is
also playing a vital role in the
development of global interactive Earth
system models so here are some
application examples in for which in
which scientists can apply the modest
data in their scientific research in the
first case our scientists Annette from
UC Berkeley wants the surface
temperature data across the globe at 100
100 kilometer resolution as the input
for her climate model and in a second
model on scientists the bath law from
oregon state university wants the
monthly leaf area index for the year two
thousand three over the Metolius ameri
flux tower sites to compare the
satellite data with her ground-based the
sensor data so in the cert k
our scientists young Rio Rio once fought
also from UC Berkeley once for different
atmosphere products and five different
land products across the whole US area
for all years when data are available at
one kilometer resolution and the finest
the time granularity available to
investigate the land if ever
transpiration actually we've been
working with young wheel during this
whole summer and his application has
become our first working example as for
now scientists who want to use Modi's
data in their research have met all the
data entry barriers we mentioned above
as for data collection the modest source
data are published across multiple FTP
sites and the metadata was separately
maintained and not convenient for query
as for data transformation different
related products have different time
granularities and space imaging
resolutions but and more mostly an even
worse situation was that different
products have different geography
project types the so-called swass type
and the signal oil type so if Sunday's
to want to do analysis over mouth over
multiple data products which have
different project types we have to
reproject the swass type source data
files into the single soil fast so that
to provide a uniform format for for the
scientists will talk about the display
details about the rear projection later
and for the data management in our
working example we we need to process
totally 10 years of our interested
modest data products for the whole US
area and we need to download and then
process around five eighty-five thousand
solve source data files which requires
thousands of CPU hours and several
terabytes of data storage an important
feature of this
task is that all these source data
processing tasks can be totally
embarrassed embarrassingly parallel so
this gives us enough reason to leverage
the most advanced to super computing
technologies to finish our mission so we
have proposed a cloud-based solution in
which we constructed a modest data
reproduction and reduction pipeline in
Microsoft Windows Azure cloud computing
platform so we have significant we can
significantly reduce a lower the
resource entry barriers for scientists
by leveraging the high flexibility and
scalability of cloud computing and also
the complexities involved in data
collection reproduction and management
are totally hidden from the domain
scientists and they can easily interact
with our pipeline by using a web portal
interface and finally we provided a
generic reduction service for our
scientists to upload their arbitrary
executables to perform scientific
analysis work on those reproductive data
so this pipeline can automatically
fulfill all these complex tasks for our
scientists okay so I have to interrupt
here to show you to initialize a demo
because it takes some time to finish so
i wish you show you the web the oh this
is the azure management web UI so as you
can see we've deployed one web portal
which is a real web web row and we also
had background processing instance in
which we have a hundred and fifty like
different types of worker roles we will
discuss that later and now we are both
directory to the web portal so this is
the web site application web brocation
hosted in azure
so we will request for reduction service
and this is this is currently a
preliminary interface which is works for
our example so we will request days I
will request like day 1 to day 15 here
and for satellites I will choose terror
and I will input my email here because I
will receive notification emails about
the status and so this is the dialog box
which i can upload an arbitrary
executable file so as my reduction stage
executable so but here I would just use
the default executable follow for a
working example and for the target tires
means different locations so geography
key locations i will only choose one so
and then i will submit my request only
for the geographic locations oh yeah
this is just I mean kind of convention
which is used in the geographic field so
this actually are 15 total 15 geographic
locations which divided the whole US
area so yeah this is just a convention
so the H means horizontal index and V
means the the vertical index which
divided what kind of makes a gridded
global yeah so if you won't be more
details if you have again i'll show you
later
a map yeah so so actually we are really
in a preliminary phase of our web
interface in the future we will show
more kind of yeah inclusive so okay as
you already see I've already received an
email notification which saying like
reduction job already created and it
shows the summary of our requests like
day one Tuesday 15 okay so we are just
to wait while the background is
processing our web requests and get back
so before are we I introduce our
pipeline architecture I want to first
introduce some basic features of Windows
Azure platform so the computation
obstruction as provided by Windows Azure
is called hosted services it may consist
to two different types of rows the web
role is a web application which is
accessible via via an HTTP and the
worker role is a background processing
application so both developers can
specify a different number of post type
of work of the rose we're at the
deployment and also Windows Azure has
provided a dynamic scalability support
in which as with the recently released
them so called management API we can
also upgrade the numbers of instance
during runtime and also Windows Azure
provided three main storage services
which is an obstruction of the storage
so the first type is blob service this
is the storage for those entities such
as binary files and data files and the
queue service this is a reliable
persistent q model for messaging within
and between the hosted services and the
table services is our structured storage
in the form of tables and with simple
query support in this slide shows an
overview of our data processing pipeline
so as we can see it mainly consists of
three different stages the data
collection stage the reprojection stage
and analysis reduction stage and users
can submit their request through the as
your web bro by using our web portal
interface and the and the request will
be sent to the pipeline for processing
and in each stage as a single task will
not be initialized until the input until
the input are all ready for that
specific type for that specific task and
and in each stage there are there are
different numbers of as your worker
roles so for that specific type of
suggest data collections tasks and the
reproduction tasks and also reduction
tasks and as we as we see by using the
management API we can dot dynamically
add adjusted numbers of worker role
instances so that's we can provide a
high flexibility and scalability for our
service to fulfill different application
requirements uh yeah yes so yeah so yeah
we are kind of in an early stage for our
web interface design and this is only
this on this interface only works for
our working example I yeah as I
mentioned there is a science
environmental research group in UC
Berkeley are using currently using the
application but in the near future will
provide more generic interface like user
can specify different data products and
like the different reduction logic that
kind of stuff okay so i will go over
each stage in more details we we put the
data collection into a single
independent stage because if the data
collection itself is a complex process
because
first there are huge numbers of source
data files and each only cover covers a
small fraction of the geography area and
also the meta data for those for each
source data files such as the time frame
and the the the area coverage were main
women maintained a as sure tables and so
if we need to fetch a source data file
which covers a specific time frame and
area we have to query the metadata
metadata in as you work table and this
table 1 shows are the data product
properties for the whole us continent
over 10 years which is for our again
working example as we see the number of
source data files ranges from tens to
hundreds of thousands source data files
and the data size ranges from tens of
gigabytes to several terabytes and the
total size for 10 years will be around
four terabytes of storage and almost
around six hundred thousands of sorts at
the files so as for the reproduction
process as we saw there are huge numbers
of source data files and for and we can
put all those reprojection tasks into
totally parallel single tasks so this
picture shows an idea about how the
reprojection is done so if the left of
picture shows the source data which are
in swass format but what our scientists
need is the so-called senior soil format
of data in which so we have to rearrange
the data points in the source data into
a kind of regular shaped and regularly
arranged data format so as you can
roughly see the shaped area consists of
three separate source data files and in
order to make the target
senior seubert on top file we were it's
not a case of simple cut and paste but
rather it involves quite complex
computation and as this figure shows the
zooming view for our previous slide so
the large circle points are actually the
data points from the source data and the
little dots are the data points in our
target data files so there's kind of
misalignment there for the target data
file we have millions of data points but
in the source data files we have kind in
tens of thousands of data points so to
find out the value for each data point
we have to find the nearest that
geographical near is the point to fit
into that data point so as we need to
process the data file our pixel by pixel
so it is really compute intensive and
time-consuming process and to generate a
single target tile it usually takes
about several minutes to finish next I
will discuss some our some of our early
experiences with the reduction service
so we we want to provide the support for
arbitrary reduction executable tool
upload because we think it can bring
bring a lot of benefits for our
scientists for example scientists are
then free to use most up-to-date
scientific processing tools and generate
most advanced results and also the rid
it can significantly reduce the
scientific process development time
across multiple iterations because
scientists we're no longer depend on the
assist of some computer developers to
modify the architecture for them and
also we want to particularly discuss the
problem of running
at lat or in Ezra because we think
MATLAB is really very commonly used by
our scientists in their analysis work so
we cannot install matlab in Azure
because as really doesn't provide an
administrator privilege in their role
instances but even if we can install
matlab there ask you potentially some
legal license issues which are not still
we just do not clear today so we chose
the alternative by running standalone
executable which are generate which can
be generated by the MATLAB compiler from
those matlab code as made by scientists
so there are some zeros do some tricks
here chicks there to resolve the library
dependencies to running those standalone
executables in nature but I have no time
enough time to explain it here so if you
are interested we can definitely talk
about that after the talk and finally we
also tested the java-based the
scientific tools and they are also
supported as long as we deploy the
appropriate Java libraries along with
our application so next I want to talk
about the task scheduling in Azure so
the task scheduling model as provided in
by edger is based on cues and tables so
here I will use the projection stage as
an example so when you user when
scientists send a user request to the
pipeline the pipeline will first pass
the request into the into a service
request message and then send it to the
queue and then the service manager here
which is the reprojection service
manager will further pass the request
into a large number of single parallel
tasks reproduction tasks and for each
projection test it will also keep track
of the queue
stages from the collection stage as we
need to rely on the data collected in
the first stage to initialize the
specific repurchasing task so whenever
the inputs are already in the storage it
will dispatch the task into the
rejection task queue and also there are
a number number of worker role instance
which are doing the reprojection task
and they keep fetching tasks from this
queue and when they finish the rejection
they will send the result file into the
Azure blob storage and also they were
updated the responding status in a few
numbers of tables so this we projected
date data are all aligned and in the
unified format so they can be send it to
the next stage for scientific reduction
computation so in such a large-scale
data intensive distributed computing
environment tasks can fail for many
reasons so we have to prepare for that
and there are a few number some example
reasons here so the source data files
may be broken or missing from the FTP
sites so a specific projection task may
not be able to finish and also the
reduction tool by scientists may may run
in this function and crash during the
execution and finally there can
occasionally be some unpredictable
system errors which happened to the edge
or services so we okay so so the photo
is so we implemented the service monitor
which keeps track of the status of each
active task so we were the ability
includes to restart the task and cancel
task if it fails after several numbers
of retries and also all the service
status are persistent in azure cable so
if a service monitor if the service
monitor is self crashed it can still
resume the status when it
guess running again okay this slide
shows some preliminary result by running
multiple instance of as your worker
rolls for and we use an example as 1500
with projection tasks running in
different numbers of instance and also
by as the main st estimation running
that on desktop so in Windows Azure the
tasks can be finished in no more than
several hours but as out an estimation
the to process the same task on the
desktop it requires like days to finish
and this shows that we can get as high
as like 90 x speed up for the task okay
so in conclusion we have significant
thing we can play lower the results and
data entry barriers for scientists to
conduct research on Modest data and we
leverage the windows azure cloud
computing to provide high flexibility
and scalability and also our attack
architecture can be easily modified to
incorporate other in science
applications with similar computation
atoms so in the future work I will
specifically want to talk about the
validation the requirement of a
validation process for those arbitrary
uploaded reduction to us because we
cannot guarantee a scientist will are
always upload to correct functionally
tools or it can be vulnerable to some
mail some villagers upload so we have to
prepare for that but that remains to be
an open question and also we are
interested in replying MapReduce
framework such as dryad and drive at
link in future alright check out so I'll
take Oh unfortunately it seems the
service still processing our task so so
it so but I've requested the tasks
before so it
finally it will kind of send us back a
link to the results by running our
reduction tour so we can simply download
the package to our local machines all
right thank you and do your a couple
points yep yeah
yeah yeah thanks for asking I didn't
have enough time to explain that so as
we can see from the comparison this is
really a kind of high-end backstop we
have in the research group so it has
kind of almost double the frequency and
double the memory of the equivalent
single as your instance so we expect
like a single for single instance
comparison the desktop outperforms the
azure but by running multiple instance
right as in our pipeline architecture so
we can still gain like 90 x speed up by
running 150 instance so as for a fair
comparison right so we didn't provide a
precise result in the in the in the
testing on the deck step up because it
takes days to finish and we haven't be
able to do that so this is based on the
average time but we run a month a few
number of single tasks and get averaged
together estimation of the overall time
so we just want to give scientists a
sense like how fast their they can get
results back by using windows azure
rather than if they have like very
limited computational resource on their
research group such as a single desktop
so we can make the that much faster we
have time for one more question yes
yes yeah currently we only support the
nearest paper type of reprojection and
in the future we will kind of implement
like some other types of vino there
there's a few numbers of methods but
this one fits to the working example
specific working example as required of
our Sunday so we make this as a first
choice yeah thanks thank you